certaines de ces marques et les ajuster et
aussi parfois il y a un problème d'arrondi
qui survient entre le
scribe informatique qui est avec le membre du grand jury
et le scribe britannique, c'est le
dossier du scribe britannique qui a la
priorité, eh bien, c'est un excellent résultat pour
la foule française  avoir deux cavaliers dans
la spéciale c'est au détriment de euh le
cheval d'Isabelle Bir Bella Rose
forfait hier soir mais ça veut dire que Mark
Bo peut rouler dans la spéciale aujourd'hui pour la
France sans âme de concept de rêve
[Musique]
7.68606
et il a gagné la spéciale à  le spectacle
cinq étoiles de Rotterdam a
également bien performé dans cette classe de beon
et
[Music]
Dil a peut-être légèrement sous-performé
par rapport au gilet personnel du Grand Prix
ici à Co, ils veulent donc
tout sortir du sac aujourd'hui pour reproduire certains
de ces scores spéciaux gagnants  ils ont
eu dans leur
[Musique] un
passage temporel de cette activité hors réelle
[Musique]
Cadence 8.1 arrivant pour sa moitié de passe
au début
sur une note élevée
et une tendance de plus de 75% au
moment [Musique] à moitié passe [
Musique]
toujours  J'ai obtenu beaucoup de notes supérieures à
huit pour le travail de passage avec ce
cheval [Musique], une bonne transition ainsi qu'un peu
élevé devant, peut-être juste au
moment même de
la transition [Musique], le
traduisant en
passage au Trot étendu pour faire la guerre au spécial, je
me concentre vraiment sur ceux-là.  des marques distinctes
sur les transitions ainsi que vers et hors de
[Musique]
Paces Bob, ils ont toujours une tendance supérieure à
75%
[Musique]
c'est une transition difficile de venir
ici, un autre cheval anticipe juste
légèrement avant que le PF ne soit complètement
établi, probablement une étape  ou Too Short
là
[Musique]
vraiment ouais le PF
5.6 donc à travers le premier passage
Serpentine Loop à PF encore une
fois ce passage Serpentine
Loop les prépare pour la
transition ascendante vers
caner et Mark
bobly que euh le passage PF Serpentine
là a vraiment fait descendre les marques
5,9, le premier travail de passage de PF était si
fort que vous seriez assez déçu par le
fait qu'il était en hausse d'environ
75% après avoir obtenu 8 8,5 probablement un n ou deux
pour le travail de passage des demi-
passes au tout début du
test
[  Musique]
passe
[Musique]
bien deux fois très rapidement suivi d'
une fois
[Musique] ce que
j'aime chez ces deux temp,
c'est qu'ils obtiennent un score de 7,1 en
moyenne, juste
au-dessus du taux d'acquisition de points ici
dans le
concept de double rêve Sol.  jusqu'à la
ligne centrale cter pirouettes une séquence temporaire
cter
pirouette prochaines questions à laquelle
[Musique] a
répondu
[Musique]
la DI avec transition juste un petit
trébuchement à venir
euh la fin de cette note basse pour ces
neuf un morceau temporaire entre le euh  deux
pirouettes cter avec les pirouettes bien
notées marquant environ 7 et demi pour les
deux
donc c'est la ligne médiane finale P bage
pour Mark bble et Noble dream
concept Sal
il va prendre la tête je
dirais mais juste par les plus grandes marges  et
c'était un test très très fort
au départ, même si le contre-travail était
resté exactement tel qu'il était, le
travail du passage PF au milieu du
passage PF Serpentine juste avant que le
travail du Canter soit
vraiment martelé est réduit d'un
possible 74 à environ
70,5  Mark wble noble dream concept sel le
maire de 12 ans par
kont par P delar Laura delar Jean Lou
darara et ils sont les bénéficiaires d'
Isabel ver retrait de cloche Rose
hier 31 dans le Grand Prix on
va tenir la tête ici  pour le
moment ce matin dans la spéciale Grand Prix
mais rejoint par euh Richard
Davidson Richard bonjour à vous,
euh alors que vous vous installiez, vous avez eu l'
occasion de regarder beaucoup d'
essais de Mark et il y avait beaucoup à aimer,
oui, il y en avait  et en fait je n'en ai pas
vu le début
parce que
euh cette épreuve spéciale de Grand Prix vous savez
est très forte au début avec
des TR prolongés et des passages euh et donc
évidemment quand vous avez un cheval comme
celui-ci qui est vraiment fabuleux dans les deux
mouvements c'est pourquoi ils obtiennent des scores
très élevés, nous regardons maintenant les
demi-passes et euh, assez intéressant,
les demi-passes sont plus faciles dans ce test
que dans le Grand Prix euh en théorie,
ils ont exactement le même angle mais vous
voyez, vous pouvez commencer un  un peu, vous savez un
mètre plus tôt ou terminer un mètre plus tard,
vous avez un peu de marge pour le faire et
euh, si un cheval trouve One Way un peu plus difficile
que l'autre, vous pouvez le rendre un
peu plus facile en fait, c'est un
test moins technique
euh  que le sol F donc euh tant que
vous avez un cours pour pouvoir
passer et prolonger le TR, la première partie
du test, vous savez que vous êtes en
affaires, avait également une vraie concentration sur
les transitions avec beaucoup de
notes spécifiques pour les transitions en  le
spécial je pense que le score de Mark est sur le point
d'
être remis donc tellement triste pour Isabelle ver mais aussi
génial pour nos nombreux détenteurs de billets français
d'avoir l'opportunité de voir non pas un
mais deux de leurs coureurs aujourd'hui Mark
wobble noble dream concept Soul 70